This American garnish stops right here
and stops right now it was darker than
most inaugural addresses he basically
took the hide off everybody sitting on
that platform not a Muslim president
Trump is defending a temporary travel
ban after weekend of angry demonstration
Michael Flynn general plan is a
wonderful man I think he's been treated
very very unfairly by the media we
learned the length of the president's
views 28 days we were ranting and raving
I'm just telling you you know you're
dishonest people we're going to be
living with Obamacare for the
foreseeable future what do you have
after a big conspicuous legislative
defeat finger-pointing and
recriminations nobody knew that health
care could be so complicated president
Trump's first meet to a joint session of
Congress covered all the issues the
president honored the heroism of Navy
SEAL Ryan Ellen
Ryan's legacy is etched into eternity
thank you
we live in a very polarizing time do you
think your dad is contributed to that is
predates my father
I ordered a targeted strike in Syria
President Trump is facing its first
international crisis and now know he
will not hesitate to use military force
North Korea is a big problem and we will
deal with that very strongly North Korea
still says it wants peace but it becomes
too
they're ready to fight President Trump
has had a bumpy start to his presidency
here the president named somebody they
all quite like and now it has come to
fruition and I got it done in the first
100 days that's even nice